hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
it's the 17th of April and you're
watching games but news your number one
source for news on gamespot which also
happens to be to the occasional Star
Wars story today is one of those days
today it's a star wars celebration in
Anaheim Disney unveils another tape the
trailer from the seventh installment of
the force awakens the trailer is our
second glimpse of the film the first
being a teaser released in november of
last year it's pretty glorious so if
you're into Star Wars you'll definitely
want to take two minutes out of your day
to watch the whole thing as for Star
Wars video game news EA and dice of said
they'll unveil new details about star
wars battlefront tomorrow at ten-thirty
a.m. PDT the force awakens will hit
cinemas on December 18 of this year next
up some sad news as Borderlands the
pre-sequel developer 2k australia has
shuts down 2k australia marked the last
Triple A studio left in Australia and
were previously part of a rational game
they helped to develop games such as
SWAT for the Bioshock series and the
bureau XCOM declassified s'okay has
released an official statement to Kotaku
saying we can confirm we have taken
steps to begin the studio closure
process for 2k Australia in order to
better manage ongoing development costs
while improving the working proximity of
our creative teams here at gamespot we
wish all the very best to the talented
team affected by the studio closure and
finally the witcher 3 wild hunt is that
much closer to being in our hands as the
game has gone gold today developers that
a project have confirmed that the game
is all done and ready to go ahead of its
release next month across xbox one ps4
and PC set-up reacts boss Adam Badowski
set of the project quote we worked so
damn hard
the past three years to bring you this
game we literally spent tens of
thousands of hours to turn all that into
an adventure that will kick your ass and
make you want to come back for more let
me know down in the comments if you
reckon the witcher 3 can live up to all
of this type and why or why not you can
add against all we've got stories on
some sweet blood-borne gear and Jenny
you have full resolution those are all
the things that I wanted to tell you
about today do you remember that
tomorrow I'll have my top five story of
the whole gaming week so check back with
me then to get all caught up